hey this is presh talwalkar
this problem comes from an early round
of the norwegian mathematical olympiad
the numbers a b and c are positive
integers
an apple cost eight dollars
a banana cost b dollars
and a cherry cost c dollars
the cost of b apples
b bananas and a plus b cherries is 77
what would be the cost for one apple
two bananas and one cherry
i thank oscar for sending me this puzzle
by email
it seems like it's impossible to solve
from the given information and it stumps
many people
students were given about five minutes
on average to solve problems like this
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
so let's translate the given information
into a mathematical equation
the total cost will equal the cost of an
apple times the number of apples
plus the cost of a banana times the
number of bananas
plus the cost of a cherry times the
number of cherries
we know that an apple cost 8
a banana costs b dollars and a cherry
cost c dollars
furthermore we know the total cost is 77
to make this a little easier to read
i'll remove the dollar signs
now we know we have b apples
b bananas and a plus b cherries
so we can substitute in those values
so what can we do with this equation
let's continue to see if there are any
patterns in this equation
notice that the first two terms
have a common factor of b
so let's factor that b out and we have b
times the quantity a plus b
in this next equation
we have a common factor of a plus b
so we'll factor that out and we have a
plus b times b plus c equals 77
now we need to take advantage of another
piece of information we were given
the numbers a b and c are positive
integers
this means
a plus b
and b plus c
have to be factors of 77.
so what are the factors of 77 what two
numbers could multiply together to be 77
well they're only a few possibilities it
can either be 1 times 77 or 77 times 1
or it can be 7 times 11 or 11 times 7.
those are the only possibilities
because 7 d7 has prime factors of 7 and
11.
since a b and c are positive integers we
also know that a plus b and b plus c
have to be two or larger
they cannot be one
so this further removes the possibility
that one of the factors is one so we can
eliminate the top two cases
this means we know the two factors are
going to be 7 and 11 or 11 and 7
and this will be what's needed to solve
the problem
we want to find out the cost for one
apple two bananas and one cherry
we can write this out as a plus two b
plus c
we can split up two b
into two terms of b
and then we can group this equation
as a plus b
plus b plus c
so the question is asking
what is the sum of the factors a plus b
and b plus c
well it could either be 7 and 11 or it
can be eleven and seven
and either way
it's going to be a total of eighteen
and that's our answer
the cost will be
eighteen dollars
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can support me on patreon and you
can check out my books which are listed
in the video description you can also
catch me on social media either at
mindyourdecisions or at preshtalwalker